big ticket back welcome back to the gym
Julian podcast get out for that don't
make a fart noise that our intro what's
wrong with you okay come back I could
take the mic with me be welcome back to
the gym and Julian podcast where this
week's episode is brought to you by save
$10 a line - okay sometimes you have to
make a few fart noises just a few two
minutes me Jenna please give me the page
well you told God I said okay Kai
seriously though there are no sponsors
this week we are sleep deprived we just
finished our 24 hour stream we started
at 6 a.m. Saturday morning we ended 6
a.m. this morning
we slept from 7 a.m. until late this
afternoon so we are a little I'm out of
it I'm out of it slept okay let's quote
things ignore tations for no reason 24
hours we literally woke up today 8 and
now we hear I don't know where I am I
don't know what day it is
yeah we knew we knew that this podcast
was gonna be just kind of all over the
place because well the I don't know we
we've been up for 24 hours before
because we've like pulled all-nighters
for videos and whatnot but yeah I do
that often I feel yeah I realized that
the other day like I was going to bed at
like 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning I was
like I woke up just like a few hours
after now in the morning I'm pretty much
been over 20 bars like you kinda can
just happen busy but yet but I feel like
we do that enough where you're for a lot
of different reasons not like super
frequently but like there are plenty of
days where you've stayed up for 24 hours
and I xx of this more does anything in
the past you used to like get
non-functional at like a certain amount
of time
where you weren't sleeping like you just
like you would shut off but I really do
feel like staying awake and function
without sleep as a skill that you can
get better out I don't think that makes
it like good for you or like that you
should do it but like literally in the
army or there's like different groups of
whatever Green Berets what they there
was that TV show where they show like
their training and it's like the most
insane [ __ ] you've ever seen but
specifically part of their training is
like staying up for days in a row like
you can get good at it yeah it's like
anything else well I wasn't like
exhausted during the 24 hour stream like
sleep wise so I was okay I mean you do
start to go a little crazy because
you've been playing video games for 24
hours straight yeah but I feel like like
you said like anything else you can just
get good at staying up you get better at
at least yeah like I remember when I
first met you and we used to you know it
was new to me to stay up all night I
mean obviously I went to college so I
had those occasional nights but it was
nothing like when we would have to stay
up all night ending or shooting or both
so yeah welcome Internet yeah welcome to
the Internet more like and like but yeah
so it wasn't quite being tired like you
ready to go to sleep for me it was just
like I'm done being on yeah because
being on is what is your yeah you're
being watched there's no moment where
like throughout your day even if you go
to it you know an office job or wherever
you where you go you generally are like
in front of people or you're interacting
with people and when you have moments to
yourself like whether you're on a
cigarette break or you go to the
bathroom and you're on the bus or
whatever put your headphones in you're
at the gym you're able to just kind of
like turn off and just you don't get
that on the 24 hour stream because
there's every single second you're being
watched and that that that is one hour
20 you're just like I'm cool staying up
I just don't want to be streaming that
was like my thought but it was a
brilliant time and the support was
mental and twitch put us on the front
page and it was [ __ ] it was so cool
it was just great really fun time but I
mean just yeah although today was cheats
a and I already had some really good
food so I felt really good about
you know I had good food today too and
we don't have a sponsor this week but
post mates did spot us 30 bucks because
they knew we were doing a stream 424 it
was so nice and they sponsored the
podcast so I'm just saying they just
literally DM Julianne during his stream
and they were like just in case you need
some like food later here's $30 yeah
it's really nice
and I took them up on that ship all
right I want you to tell me until my
friends hear about this new shell that
you found oh my god
it is like it you fell asleep the other
night cuz I was watching Hulu I really
like Hulu by the way like I think I
think I watch Hulu more than I watch
Netflix I definitely want you to and
then watching Netflix and I watch
Netflix just to watch the office and
Breaking Bad over and over just like by
those and like have that you don't need
a streaming service to watch the same
buy a DVD mind if everything is when
Julian no longer says can i he only says
kai
like a toddler kygo bathroom
okay I go bathroom why is it that when
you combine those two words into Kai it
just makes you sound completely like a
child
cuz that's funny like that's what little
kids sound like okay go on I have some
mac and cheese okay go Kyle go Kyle go
Johnson's house John conjunction
what's your abs there are so many things
that can make that noise that's not a
fart maybe don't generalize please like
what name when you make a fart noise
with your armpit that's not a fart noise
that's a artificial noise just so I was
watching like I think I watched the most
recent Bachelorette which is man I hate
that show but I just continue to watch
it but it you know who are you looking
it I don't know you hate when I say talk
questions on the mics are just Ericka
Mike alright I'm talking
relax I'm just trying to power on this
is a dog bed over here audio sounds
great I'm wearing a bathrobe but it's
like kind of hot in here like okay we're
struggling today y'all but so I was
watching like the newest episode of The
Bachelorette or whatever and you know
Hulu or Netflix will just start playing
like another Sulu I think in particular
I'll just start Holmes laying another
show after it they autoplay just to get
you yeah like so many times at night
like I'll put on an episode that I
wasn't able to watch that week you know
whatever aired and like you'll be like
yeah I want to watch it three seconds
later you're asleep I watched the entire
episode no like I'm telling you how I'm
telling you how I got there
okay so Julie it'll be asleep and then
something else that's all my people who
fall asleep and I really do like you
fall asleep and I just cannot like I
just sit there like I can't fall asleep
so I'm watching The Bachelorette and
then like I've found myself in like the
weirdest I guess like you know you fall
down at YouTube hole this is a Hulu home
like you'll be watching I don't know
a cupcake show and then all of a sudden
that I watched an entire season or two
seasons of like some Wall Street
television show that was on in like the
90s like I just watch the weirdest stuff
that I don't need for myself but
sometimes I'm kind of down like if I'm
invested I'm invested so I don't watch
any live television anymore unless it's
on like YouTube TV but even that's like
all go in there with an intention of
watching something alive you know like
I'm gonna tune in to this show something
specific yeah yeah like oh that show
that I like is on an 8 p.m. I'm gonna
watch it live on Hulu I'm not often a
YouTube TV I'm often like browsing live
television for something to watch yes
so I don't watch any like Network show
so we no longer have cable so I let the
Hulu just start playing whatever was
playing after it and I hear this like do
it did this giant [ __ ] stage and this
guy and his shoe and he's like welcome
to the proposal and I get to space my
intention is here what the proposal was
like you have to explain what it looks
like cuz behind him it literally looks
like like some she looks like the voice
it was like the off season of the voice
like that kind of stage those kind of
what it's like a dark weird like no but
I'm just saying like you have to
describe like where like before the
audience it shows up like he looks like
he's in this like vortex of black and
like silver it's like creepy so I'm
letting it play and I hear welcome to
the proposal and I'm like okay my you
have my attention yes and [ __ ] what and
he's like I like I don't know if anybody
knows what this show is like I haven't
seen anybody like laughing about it on
Twitter or anything like that's where I
get all of my information and I haven't
seen anybody it's a show where they
pageant style they have a bachelor or a
bachelorette like they do a montage in
the beginning where they're like let's
meet our shooter and the entire persons
it's like black mirror the entire
person's like body is galaxy doubt in
this like gray blobby or literally the
same exact if I'm jumping in here late
early the same exact effect that used in
the leftovers
remember the intro to the leftovers like
season 3 where it was like a picture of
a family except one of them was galaxies
down yeah it was like that like exactly
like that if you've seen that it look
like blob people and they're doing like
a voiceover they do and they're doing
like a voiceover and they seem like nice
normal regular people and then I'm like
there's no way this is real there's no
way that they're doing this they're like
alright so let's let's meet our our
candidates or whatever they walk down a
gigantic staircase they all come out
they read the description of them like
like they're doing a pageant they're
like here's Karen Chu loves playing the
trumpet and she also has a giant
collection of baseball cards since she
rollerskates
free time they walk out and like they're
little they're cocktail dress and then
they all stand there and I'm like this
is the weirdest thing ever they can't
see the shooter because the shooter is
sitting inside of a pod behind a black
wall and I'm like this is black mirror
this is a giant there's like sparkling
lights and just it's the biggest
production for like the stupidest
[ __ ] thing and you could ever imagine
you you like see this whole bit about
the suitors life but you never see their
face yeah you never see their face and
so the people and the pageant can't see
their face either because they're
sitting behind a pod so then like you
know however long couple minutes of
people coming down the stairs and
walking out there I'm like okay this is
weird like I'm laughing like there's no
way that anyone's taking this seriously
like this is a joke right like it's a
it's a happy it's a mean like you guys
are doing this is fun here like I okay I
think I get it and then all of a sudden
they're like okay shooter they address
them by their name like Mike who would
you you out of these lovely you know 15
ladies why don't you go ahead and pick
seven that you'd like to get to know
better and I'm like oh oh oh you're
really just making him do it right off
the bat just based on least they've said
nothing yet yeah so then they eliminate
them based on looks and description
alone like a car they pick seven or
however five people I don't know eight
and then I'm like no way this is wild
what the [ __ ] else is gonna happen then
he's like alright so after the break
since physical appearance is such an
important part of a relationship now
we're gonna get to know our contestants
a little better by by doing the next
portion of this in their swimwear and
I'm like no [ __ ] way there's no way
no yeah they come out and they're
[ __ ] in their swimsuits like it's not
a joke it's basically like they're
trying to condense the dating process
well not only condense it they're trying
to fit the whole dating process - one
person so half the dating process that
covers the the the basically existence
of the whole couple into twenty minutes
so they're like okay here are like three
traits about this
person like he said like a dog or like a
[ __ ] car like your three traits okay
do you not like that one shove that one
aside okay now you have to see what it
looks like naked here they are naked
yeah it's like it's literally like
condensing so they come out in their
swimsuits and this is all like just
wildly assuming that all of these women
would like to date this man which no one
has seen yet like literally not even so
then they come up and I was I was
pleasantly surprised by the swimsuit
portion they didn't really focus a lot
on there yeah it wasn't like it wasn't
like as bad as I thought it could have
been like a lot of those girls came out
in tank tops and shorts I'm like that's
cute like I I appreciate that and then
there was like this glimmer of time when
I was like oh these people are serious
and oh this is legit or like that's kind
of nice so like they would come out and
you'd expect them to give these like
really nervous pageant answers which
there were a couple of and they're
hysterical they're so funny because
these people just freeze up under these
lights because why the [ __ ] wouldn't
look what the [ __ ] are we doing but but
you know the he hands this girl the mic
the first one Jessica or whatever
indicating her great picture
yeah and he's like okay so she comes out
in your swimsuit and they're like little
cover up and she's got she's holding a
[ __ ] book and you're like sick and
he's like alright you know why don't you
tell our suitor Mike something about
yourself and she's like okay well since
you know I'm here
I want to be vulnerable and she takes
off her cover up and the crowd goes wild
and I'm like this is kind of nice and
you know she's like I'm looking for a
guy my god I know what you're gonna say
I'm not gonna say no I know which part
you're gonna talk about I remember what
you're talking about now I'm just
talking about the anxiety thing that she
says or the depression thing oh no that
was Morgan God I mean uh if you guys
want to watch it you can of this I don't
thing to do with it it's it's bizarre to
watch I'm just describing like what the
show is in case you don't want to watch
my bad way to blame here but so she
takes off her cover up and she's like
you know I just want to be vulnerable
and then she's like holding a scrapbook
of her family and describing that she
really is looking for someone I'm like
wait a second this is like this is legit
like this that was really nice what she
said and that was felt honest and real
yeah and I also noticed that every time
they cut to commercial break they're
using like
there have a live audience there but
that they're definitely using some like
crowd noises - like amp up the energy
because every time he goes alright well
we'll come back right after this break
and you hear the same clip of this guy
going yeah cuz if anyone's response -
we'll be back after this is yeah the
same break it's that same guy screaming
yeah so been the heat you know he
finally whittled it down to a couple or
whatever and he walks out and then the
the whole thing is that he's gonna
propose to one of them and he he does he
proposes to one of them after they come
out in their evening wear and they have
to like plead their case as to why they
make a good wife or something but then
the editing and the the last like scene
I'm not gonna spoil it in case you want
to watch it but like the last sort of
scene of the show it's like it just was
the most black mirror thing I've ever
seen because the crowd is cheering on
these two complete strangers who have
just decided to get engaged for no
reason other than a television show and
they keep cutting back and forth between
them kissing
Peach's outside that door by the way
them kissing and the girl that has been
standing and like saying that she'll
love him and honor him and cherish him
is walking up the stairs like to
backstage and they keep cutting back and
forth between that girl walking people
cheering and screaming them kissing and
there's like fake fireworks going off
they're like what the hell what the hell
I mean okay like at least of the
bachelor or the Bachelorette like
there's no live studio audience reacting
you to someone be like I choose you
first and they're not doing it at the
same time so that the person that gets
rejected is like physically present to
get rejected for sure but what they used
to do that in Flavor of Love and like
Rock of Love well let me pose this this
way to you like because you've watched
The Bachelor a lot a lot more than I
have let's just say that like I have
haven't seen all the seasons like I'd
say the last but you're I would say like
you're I don't know you've watched The
Bachelor enough to like kind of BTech be
desensitized to like what it is because
it's a ridiculous concept yeah but
you've watched everything's ridiculous
yeah no I know but I'm just saying like
it is a pretty ridiculous concept but
the more you watch it it just becomes
like a TV show and you're just like okay
it's entertainment like it's fine but
like I watch it cuz I [ __ ] hate it
okay let me get to my point
my point is the live studio audience is
super black Mary because it's like the
audience reacting in front of what's
happening it's a live version of The
Bachelor I know but what I'm saying is
that's already what's been happening
with The Bachelor ever since the
bachelor started or anything like it
where it's like okay you're literally
like you're dating a straight your
stranger dating a stranger everyone's
rich and beautiful and suddenly like
millions and millions of people love you
and it that's our that's black mirror
[ __ ] has already been existing now it's
just in one room happening all at once
well yeah but that's what I just said
the worst black mirror part about it is
that if you're a person in the audience
you're cheering for these people that
just got engaged while simultaneously
cheering up [ __ ] girl that's walking up
the stairs and backstage got rejected
yeah I know the fact that it's live in
front of people is so insane I think
it's just as insane to have that much
disagreement but yeah so anyways no but
you're right you're right I get it but
it was just like the most ridiculous
show I've ever seen so then obviously
there were two episodes and you had
fallen asleep long before this so I
watched the whole first thing in sort of
like disbelief and I'm like oh there's
another episode Thank You Hulu for
cueing that up for me immediately right
after the first one was over because you
know the the episode ends relatively
abruptly because it's just like yeah
fireworks
congratulations saw a new couple we'll
see you guys next time
and then it just [ __ ] the show's over
and I'm like there's no closure what the
hell is happening like what is going on
do they even live in the same location
are they ever gonna see each other again
like what the hell is this that's what I
really like about them the do week
pageant style
who's there like all right here's our
suitor you know he's from Bakersfield
here's Alexa and she's from [ __ ]
Delaware and you're like well how is
this gonna logistically work do you guys
care like does any what the hell is this
cut to episode two right and the sutras
is a sutras she's the lady's a lady and
they show you the problem and they show
you her lips in the intro video this
time she gets to see her lips but to be
fair they did give an update they were
like everyone's question was is this
real and then yeah did you already say
that in the episode - they were like
they had gone on Good Morning America or
something and they were like oh we've
been seeing each other yeah I'm like
that's cute it's kind of a couple after
the first though not sweet but like
there's no way that you guys are gonna
have a higher success rate than like it
happened one time they're not looking
for specific numbers dude okay okay yeah
it's [ __ ] out it's totally [ __ ] out
it's [ __ ] up that like it's yeah it's
weird the way the wait for me the way is
narrated Jesse Palmer is that it was I
don't know his name I think he's a
former athlete you know it sounds
familiar but he the way he hosted is
weird because he's basically like
narrating it's a beauty pageant it's a
beauty it's a beauty pageant slash date
yeah blind date yeah literally slash up
one 1/2 of a blind date those shows have
existed since forever and like you
watched them you know you think about
the really really old ones like actual
literal blind date and you're like this
is fun it's entertainment like the best
thing you could hope for is that these
people actually like each other but
logistically it's just like it's so not
possible hmm like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah I guess it's like I struggle
sometimes with like my idea of like when
I'm consuming the media right like I'm
watching it I'm having a reaction to it
it's making me angry or frustrated or
like anything and I'm like am i the the
majority of this audience or these are
the other people in the audience being
like thinking that this is
super legit or like super real no I I
think it's I think you about the
Bachelorette and the bachelor I think
it's the power of entertainment it's
like well done entertainment that's the
wrong word it's the power of like camera
and lights and Hollywood and money it's
like the moment there's some sort of
investment with with a crew of cameramen
and a network that's gonna buy it behind
anything like people automatically care
they it does not matter what the content
is the moment there's like attention to
it yeah people they care about
it's like a [ __ ] snap decision that's
why I'm just like I'm so surprised that
they even found a lot of you know young
beautiful contestants for the like
eligible people for this show because
it's like you know when they cast these
things right they don't they wouldn't
tell these people sometimes they're just
like come to a casting for ABC or
whatever and you just go and they
interview you and then you know six
months later they're like hey we're
doing a show you know all you got to do
is get on this plane that we got you for
you know Los Angeles and stay in the
hotel and you don't even really know
what you're doing you know but like
people like I just don't understand in
this day and age at this point of the
internet and media being you know
everywhere all the time
why do people still agree to do whatever
for television I don't know I really
know I mean they were like smart she's
like I'm a neuroscientist and you're
like what the [ __ ] what are you doing on
this like circus stage circus show like
well you notice how there's no one who
came from any sort of internet position
or life or job
no one is showing up they're like hey I
I produce videos for an online series or
anything like that anything close to the
internet or like I write on this
whatever my point is like you're hearing
from scientists doctors and
photographers and like people who are
just like separated from the internet
reality maybe well no that's what I
that's what I observed that's not maybe
that's what I observed like I didn't see
anyone come in who has any sort of like
degree is you're saying that someone
that that is familiar with the online
world would be less likely why the [ __ ]
were they going that show yeah I mean
well that's what I feel it yeah I mean
even if you want to go on the trash
reality dating show there's probably way
better ones and or Internet
to go on that than the proposal on ABC
yeah
well that's like what I liked about what
Trisha did on Big Brother's is like
here's a person that in no way needs to
be on a television show at all even
though she's been on every television
show ever created but like she did it
because she can and because she wanted
to and because she's such a huge
personality she knows that she can make
that show pretty [ __ ] fantastic and
she did
well like think about all the people
that they clearly cast for like the
bachelor or the Bachelorette or some
other reality TV shows like they don't
even necessarily need to be right for
the show if they're entertaining and
make great television [ __ ] it you're
you're hired get over here you know but
some of the people that were taking it
really seriously I'm just like I feel
bad for them on the site a little yeah
but not too much I mean good for them
you know maybe they were doing it with
really nice intentions of like I've been
looking for a partner for all these
years something's working [ __ ] it I'll
go on a TV show like I like to hope that
is for sure like regardless of their
education or their life or their job or
you know my main problem with this show
is that it's its centric it's like
audience reaction centric it's all based
on the live like love fare that
everyone's having cheering these
strangers on kissing and proposing and
[ __ ] when I because I'll bring up
married at first sight because that's a
good show I love that show
and I'm gonna bring that up because I
feel like that was like one of the first
dating based reality shows that I
actually felt like they they had any
sort of care or interest it was whether
or not people loved each other right it
was the first time I had seen a dating
show where they brought actual experts
and they actually had therapy and
counseling sessions and talked to them
and checked in on them and like at the
end of the show there wasn't this big
live audience and it was it was just
like they just wanted to see if this
experiment worked and they gave it every
single like piece of you know ingredient
that it might need with with all the the
relationship help that they gave them
and so you go from a show like that
which I really enjoyed because it's just
interesting it's just a human experiment
and everyone I think in
in some capacity is interested in
watching he makes grant after going from
that to a show like this where it's like
there's literally there's no they do no
team of they do relationship experts
there there's no that all they say is
our team of blue what do they say Blue
Ribbon matchmakers what the [ __ ] is a
blue ribbon matchmaker anyway I don't
know that sounds like a dog show yeah
like what in the world so they use just
like our our team of Blue Ribbon
matchmakers compiled which I [ __ ] a lot
your yeah I don't even hear that I don't
lie by there's no team of anything
casting director casting being able to
get this literally literally just a
straight-up lie that it was a team of
anything besides a casting team but
they're like yeah we've compiled and
then they walk in and it's just like
there's all this like [ __ ] show of like
people just being completely superficial
and stupid and in love for no reason
but like I hate that you know I hate in
love but I like I hate that this sort of
gives like the worst names like a dating
show right because there are I mean I
think I honestly think married at first
night and love at first trip or what is
it called life light that's on both on
TLC's yeah or they only have a certain
type of dating show but I agree with you
that it's been done in the past where
there's like you can tell the difference
between a show that maybe in theory
cares a little more about the people
that are on it what happens to their
lives and then there's shows that are
just here for like attention and ratings
and you know well I mean someone could
get taken away in an ambulance that'd be
wonderful for us you know II mean you're
right I mean again like that counter
argument can be made like nobody watched
married at first sight it was a very
nice show love that I didn't do any good
numbers like of course it didn't do
numbers like The Bachelor if you're
trying to be there if you're trying to
be the live black mirror version of The
Bachelor you've done a great job with
the proposal like if that's what you're
going for
that's a [ __ ] good job that's what I
think but like where is the line and why
is the line have sex on stage oh my god
I'm joking but I'm serious like that's
like where does it everything but why do
I love married at first sight
and you know you watch the progression
of their relationship over 90 days or
whatever and they choose to stay married
or if they want a legally divorce you
know why do I find that to be acceptable
but if two people just meet in a pageant
style thing and propose to each other
after it I'm like that is milking it
like where's my line I guess I think
where is anyone's lying
I think of entertainment and why I think
the line is when you're watching it
you're like what the [ __ ] am i watching
when you watch you feel yeah when you
watch me their first night there's so
many moments we were like you actually
can relate or you want to feel for these
people or you're invested or it grabs
you right like there's is a lot of raw
moments there just are because it's a
like a lot of the time there are cameras
there yeah but it's a pretty real
situation these people are in and they
take it very seriously for the most part
there's none of that and he's in in the
proposal or in The Bachelor there's
absolutely no every behind every corner
of anything there's a producer
organizing something to happen that's
all superficial that's all stupid and
flashy just for a number I like I
gravitate towards a show where I know
they're not it's not being produced in a
way that a reality television show might
be yeah and I agree with you that you
like I watch The Bachelor cuz I hate I
don't like I only watch it when you turn
it on but I watch it because I hate it
too I hate watch the [ __ ] out of that
show but when married at first sight is
on I'm [ __ ] invested dude yeah I'm
like yeah I want these [ __ ] to like
figure it out I want them to be happy
but if they don't I want them to split
up and be happy too yes I care about the
people that are on that show yeah
because they're full because no one
[ __ ] volunteers to be on wall you'd
think but you'd think that no one
volunteers to be unmarried of her sites
to get famous like that's not the route
that you take it's just like well
because you would get divorced what you
true true true my opinion though is like
you think about Meredith think about
married at first sight and like I'm with
you I'm not single
and I've all of my 20s I've spent in a
relationship with you and I'm so happy
and I'm like lucky and everything but if
I were single in my 20s and maybe late
into my twenties and going to my third I
mean who knows at what point am I
if I might say hey [ __ ] I'm gonna go on
married at first sight you see we'll see
what happens like literally what's the
worst that could happen well the divorce
on TV like it on a dating show or
something
yeah something where you're like [ __ ] it
right like you just finally you're like
hey what what do I have to lose by doing
this and then you just go into it like I
can relate to that a little bit in like
some other you know life yeah I agree
completely and I feel like that there's
plenty of contestants on those shows
that go on there and are just like you
know complete regular normal people with
regular lives that are genuinely maybe
looking for somebody but then you have
the awful people people that can ruin it
I just I think the the the most
important thing to me is that does it
feel authentic and that show the
proposal did have those moments of
you're like wow that was really honest
of that person or like I appreciated
that they did that or said that and that
makes me feel like they're coming from a
place that's real and so maybe I should
treat this whole thing is real but I
just [ __ ] can't because the the
showmanship of that stage and where
they're holding it just completely ruins
that moment of authenticity for me my
space cage that this person is just like
I maybe I'm so spoiled by having so much
YouTube and internet and stuff like that
in my life where I'm like I don't
necessarily want to watch somebody doing
the most ridiculous thing you've ever
seen I just I want to I want to watch
someone live their life you know I want
it to feel authentic and feel real if it
was you know something like what Shane
made of Tanna mojo the docu-series like
yes that's [ __ ] riveting I'd rather
watch that than someone you know
organize their bathroom but like I'm
still probably gonna watch that video
someone organizing the bathroom later
you know like the subject matter can be
a little more riveting given the topic
yeah but at the end of the day I want to
watch something that's far more
authentic than what is currently being
provided for us on network television
like you guys have an okay idea here
that's existed in the past of people
just at you know first sight and were
there first meeting or whittling down
from a group of people and you got to
propose to one of them like that concept
isn't bad they just make it so [ __ ]
fake and unbearable that it
like takes like completely glazes over
all those moments of honesty that these
people are maybe actually feeling yeah
you know yeah I mean and like where's
where's the trajectory going right like
in in a world where everything's just
being increasingly more extreme and nuts
and stupid for numbers like The Bachelor
like the proposal you look at like say
the first episode the bachelor ever
right like or the oldest version of that
or real world or real or whatever like
yeah I'm more focused on like the dating
thing though and then you fast forward
you're like okay let's see where this
trajectory goes 10 15 20 years from now
and you end up the proposal
okay is a live audience there's this
person's hidden into space cage with
lights on it no one can see that they
have a TV in there they can watch out
they're no longer going on a date
they're getting merrily God and at the
end of it they're getting married and
everyone loses their [ __ ] [ __ ] for
they don't even they never met you these
people they're not famous okay okay
twenty years from then what is it like
what the [ __ ] what's next you know I
mean what is the what is the more
extreme elevated weird futuristic black
mayor version of more black black mayor
versions that is you're you're gonna
have to pick a mate and then they're
gonna combine your DNA and you can have
a kid right there right right there they
have a machine you have to love your
genetic engineering gonna make the best
mate for you genetically it's called
marriage simulator Oh live marriage oh
so they they they you you're literally
they're from the time they meet to the
time that they are dead mmm-hmm and you
see in the span of a TV show somehow you
see the simulation of every fight only
kid every in the future no they wouldn't
even have to conceive it they would just
put their deal I should say that's why
I'm saying they'd have one of those
things where it grows the babies super
fast and it's not even in someone's body
and then they're like congratulations
y'all here's your baby and yes you have
a genetically engineer child and then
you'd have a fast forwarded version
simulation of a relationship and a life
and you would literally have to cheer
that on life oh that's and then yeah
when it's over uh-huh the producers walk
away to their paychecks the audience
walks away to their normalizing these
people are stuck yeah with this life and
they've picked a villain the audience
has already picked who they love and who
they've
and they're voting on it online so
everyone in the world is seeing a lie
about to inside and whether you filling
their life is completely [ __ ] really
back and they get to live in that hell
because they signed up for a television
show and all they want to do is live a
normal life after that they days of the
show they've been destroyed I'm sweating
now dude we just created an episode of
black mare I agree we just did but like
I guess that's like whenever I watched
The Bachelor I keep using that as an
example though there's plenty that have
it existed before that but like you've
seen so many instances right of like
pretty normal people or even if they're
like you know a little out there but the
way that they get edited and portrayed
in the show is like especially the
bachelor and bachelorette where each
season they desperately need that one
really unsavory person to stick around
and you clearly sad yeah they'll put
catalysts in there and set these people
up in situations where they're just like
yeah
each other you bring out the worst in
each other but they always need that one
person to have you know the audience
really dislike and the cast members
really dislike yeah they need to create
a united front right and they cast them
on purpose yeah of course and it's it's
just like when you know that why would
anyone choose to be like okay yeah land
yourself and have people hate me you
know on television why well it's that
why it's that same desire to be like on
TV at all costs that everywhere that
everyone for all of the history of TV
has had for what what's in it for you I
don't know the people who want to do
that though they're not long-term
thinkers they're not have a 10-year plan
they're just trying to get on a reality
show to make a name for themselves any
way they can
so if you're cheb and you get into a
bachelor tryout and you're like I'm
gonna be the [ __ ] heel and I'm gonna
be damn good at it but she was he was
brilliant he'll and he knew what he was
doing the whole time but like people
people like that they just know they
know that they can do it and they know
that there's a demand for it it's like
anything else I don't know it's [ __ ]
it's bizarre but I can understand why a
person like that might do it makes me
feel bad for them he does he does
[ __ ] like appearances now like that
dude
you know it just makes you feel bad for
them yeah but at the same time like you
did you feel bad for that way they
didn't edit themselves that way yes but
all of the bad edits they received may
have been part of something that they
wanted yeah sure anyways I just thought
I was like in bed laughing at that
[ __ ] show like what the hell
Wow all right so what is your prediction
for so three well they're gonna go back
to a suitor because now they've done a
suitor and a suitor us and I feel like
the pattern is boy girl boy huh
what if they did a gay episode I would
love that I they're not progressive
enough they absolutely won't whoa are
you kidding this is the most yeah I mean
I hate to agree with you but yeah I feel
like just by it you could sort of tell
who that audience was and it didn't seem
like like the same audience that watches
Dancing with the Stars
it's like older yeah it's just it's just
like what TV is it's like what the demo
of TV is old people watch TV man that
makes me [ __ ] piss old people and
young people who are disconnect from the
internet but that's it's not it's not
old people that are the problem it's
know it's old dirt not old people I mean
like like not young not Malloy I think
yeah and please don't take any of those
comments and be offended I think you
understand what I'm coming from I think
that I would love to see any gay couple
and any of any gender of any sexuality
be like we'd love to just instigate
propose to you know like if you're gonna
be a [ __ ] show at least be an inclusive
one yeah I mean that that does me the
question like when is the bachelor gonna
do that if they ever will do you think
they will ever that it's been that's
been pissing me off for [ __ ] years
and if they do it's awful lot of people
yeah just [ __ ] do it already some
nice sake um but yeah I mean I don't I
guess I don't know what the next episode
it's gonna be like but I don't even know
if I enjoy watching it either it's the
thing like it's it's a bizarre feeling
it makes me feel weird
yeah I mean I don't I don't I'm not
riveted by it like I'll be I could be up
my phone I don't
I'm not captivated that I mean that's
what that show to me is just so
surface-level
I guess I'm wondering have you ever
watched a television show that's made
you feel uncomfortable or just like you
didn't know if you were enjoying it or
not or why and like what that show
looked like that's what I feel like
about that because I I just don't I
don't even know if I'm enjoying myself I
don't know what I'm thinking I don't
know what I'm feeling it's just like a
bizarre it's a bizarre thing to me
mm-hmm yeah I don't know I don't browse
TV enough time like maybe I have kind of
think like a reality show oh no I was
gonna say broken skull ranch but that
shows dope I love that show well that's
a competent start yeah but that started
out as like what the [ __ ] yeah someone
cold like what but yeah I don't know
again like I those does Hulu those TV
those YouTube holes like they're
interesting because you find some [ __ ]
that you're like what the [ __ ] yeah but
like I don't know like do you see the
proposal as becoming a show that gets
cancelled after five episodes like it
looks like it's going to be or do you
see it being like the catalyst for like
the biggest new live bachelor version of
whatever I don't I think that they
continue to pump out that type of
television show in different formats and
see what sticks because it's like you in
theory have an endless pool of free
talent and free content
it's like talent shows yeah it's like
why you keep seeing the voice and the
four or the [ __ ] American Idol like
they can like pop it up repackage it
trash it get new hosts change the format
in some sense but it's all the same
thing in theory it's you have a bunch of
people come provide your content for you
mm-hmm you know and that's what dating
shows are yeah so yeah I don't I I'm not
sure that that show can continue to last
because how could like who the [ __ ]
you're asking people to agree to just be
married like I think at some point
you're gonna open the floodgates or just
pure trolls where everyone's just like
they'll lie to any casting director be
like oh yeah I'm really ready to get
married and then they'll get up there
and they'll be like I [ __ ] hate
everybody like I just
like you're opening yourself yeah some
trolls yeah they wouldn't invite that
though they probably like the ratings or
people watching it but I don't know I
think that even if that show doesn't
survive some other newer bachelors gonna
take note and do a live live group date
next season where they go out and do a
group date with an audience
no have you down for that no you got a
baby you dad would go do a live date no
I can go a live on Twitch date no that's
but see if you that's totally different
you know I'm Jeff you and I went live on
our date on our twitch stream that's a
totally different experience because no
one is it's not even it's not even close
it's us it's just like everything we do
our mind including our live streams are
just an extension of our well it's also
just an extension of our lives we're
giving you relat like basically
unfiltered us all the time in some some
form of content whether it's a 24 hour
stream whether it's a podcast whether
it's a vlog whether it's a video of you
turning yourself in your chair you're
giving people this like window into like
you as a human right so if we were to go
live on Twitch and go on a date it would
just be the same version of that just on
a date there's like you said there's no
producers there's no anything you know
it's like no one's like setting no one's
bringing like your father that you
haven't talked to in 30 years into this
situation you're like oh my god I'm
completely yeah or looking up what song
triggers you about your act boy
ex-boyfriend playing in the background
like yeah it's it's much more easy for
us to be like alright we're gonna go on
a live date and just live stream it
because all you have to do is be
yourself and live your life and like oh
here's a show idea what the breakup
mm-hmm
okay a couple a couple who has explored
every option to try to stay together but
will not stop fighting because they just
there he's gotten to the point where
it's like that the relationships run its
course but they haven't officially
broken up yet it's like the proposal but
it's it's the breakup version of the
proposal so they that's really sad
Julian oh yeah oh baby be sad you CTS
you see dollars and numbers I'll just
say green dollars floating out of
people's eyes
that is like that is the sell your soul
type is disgusting but imagine to make
money off of other people's tears what
the [ __ ] no you literally described it
and like at the end of the proposal
episodes
okay I'm gonna spoil something I'm not
gonna say names but when the person who
gets proposed to accepts the proposal
there's always a runner-up so you have
you get to like see them experience
losing that competition and watching
this person kiss another person who you
just proposed to that's what happens and
then the camera just stays on that
person it's like that five seconds or 20
seconds of camera time on that person
who just got crushed on TV that's just
extend that a little bit and that's what
I'm talking about yeah it is sick I was
just pinching it I feel like someone's
probably already pitched that you know I
feel like it's sick because like if you
or I were to do it like say or like
Shane let's take Shane for example what
he's doing with Tana and if they weren't
friends or Shane wasn't directly
involved in the situation every aspect
of it if he was just some producer that
was like I want to make a show about
what you're going through but you just
star in it and then I'll release it I'll
take all the credit for it I'll make all
the money off that feels exploitive
right but if Shane does it because he
it's essentially in theory about him he
also played a part in it you don't I
mean it doesn't feel exploited that's
the difference between the internet and
television yeah is that if someone's
putting it on television because this
person is crying got their heart and
soul crushed and you know something
terrible is happening to them that they
had no control over the right to [ __ ]
make a video about it no it's it feels
exploited because this television
producer that has no relation to this
but you as a person making a YouTube of
the about your own experience is not
exploited because you have the right to
our lives
that's about saying I agree that's a
good point
that's a good point that's why I feel
like it it's terrible to watch someone
just walk up the stairs and like get
rejected on TV while it a crowd is
cheering and you're like somebody made
money off of this somebody made money
off of that the hell just kidding
what the hell yeah and it wasn't him
yeah wasn't [ __ ] him someone sold
this so that that person could cry what
the hell
[ __ ] is sick dude I feel like but I feel
like this is so tame compared to what it
could be
mm-hmm it's just it's just I don't know
man this like I'm not saying it's wrong
I I'm not saying it's wrong i watch
these shows as much as anyone no it's
it's your free time just thinking about
it yeah I'm like thinking about it yeah
it's like one yeah yeah well it's you
watch that show and then you leave and
you turn it off and you're like still
thinking about just yeah I just can't
tell how it makes me feel I can't
but anyways hmm well let me know in the
comments what shows you don't know how
to feel about I guess the only thing
worse then never mind I'm not gonna say
that okay I'm just gonna hold it in for
next episode sounds good um but yeah I
don't know maybe give it a watch a few
Hulu just to see if you like it I want
to hear what you guys think of this
though I'm sure there's a lot of you who
have watched it because I know a lot of
you do the same thing as Jenna and just
fall into holes on you tongue YouTube
and Hulu and whatever so we'll see you
guys next week for another podcast and
then we're leaving town yeah we're gonna
be in China we're going to TNA here
we're going to China so we'll have to
record a podcast in advance we won't be
podcasting from China that'll be too
difficult yeah thank you guys for
hanging out thanks to all of you who
might be watching or listening that was
here for the 24 hour stream and go back
to bed no crawl back into our tunnel
you got some wonderful you have a
wonderful weekend wakes up eats food
it's about the proposal goes back to bed
such old people you guys have a
wonderful week and
[Music]
we'll see you next time start it with
one and end it with
[Music]